欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们好 这一节课我们来重点讲一下关于爆标题的三个标准框架
通过这三个标准的框架我们来点破流量的密码
首先我们要记住一个原则就是用最少的关键词覆盖最大范围的流量
让这些流量持续的沉淀才能够实现流量的暴增
就好比我们在主标题的时候 如果你都是用那些常委词 或者是全部都是一些最近上涵的词
那么你这种词它是有一定的流量期限的 比如说有些词可能就两个月或者是一个月 它流量就下降了
那么这样的词对于你这个产品持续稳定的流量是没有没办法保证的
所以说呢 我们要知道一个爆款的标题 想要它的流量持续 我们应该要布局哪些关键词 首先第一个 我们要遵循的原则就是关键词一定是跟类目是匹配的 如果关键词跟类目不匹配 就会导致你的推广评分很低 就没有办法用这些关键词去推广这个产品 导致这个产品的权重很低 那么排名就会很低 第二个就是
产品跟关键词一定要非常非常匹配 就是你的这个关键词一定是描述你的对应的产品的 而且是相对来说是比较准确的 把那些不相关的词全部不用 全部不要写在标题 第三个搭配核心的关键词 还有精准词 长尾词
一定要包含这三种类型的关键词 你的这个爆款的标题才能持久 而且它的流量的稳定性 以及它的流量的大小都会比较好 首先第一个核心词 其实我们就是我们所说的产品词 产品词 它的流量是很稳定的 而且它的周期也很长 精准词 精准词就是能够提升你这个产品的一个转化 因为很多时候
精准词搜索的时候 如果是你这个产品跟这个词非常的匹配 那么它的转化就会比较高 寻盘 DM 这些都会比较高 那么为什么要用一些长尾词呢 因为用一些长尾词就能够在前期的时候带动你整个链接的一个数据 因为长尾词它一般来说它的竞争度稍微小一点 而且它的价格便宜便宜一点
那么你在推广的时候 你就比较容易在前期让这个链接这个ID获得更多的流量 获得流量了之后呢 沉淀了数据之后 你的这些精准词核心词 它的一个推广评分就上来了
也就是这个产品有权重了 那么它的单次的点击成本就低了 那么这时候去推广这一类词 那么这一类词可以花低价格去获得一些比较好的排名
所以通过长尾词来拉动前面这两个类型的词 那么你的整个ID的数据 沉淀就比较好 沉淀比较好了之后 你的综合的数据之后 那么你的长尾词很有可能就已经拥有了自然排名了 前期是靠推广 后期就自然而然的 有了自然排名 那么你这个产品就会出现P4P流量加自然流量
同时的进行 上级成本就会比较低 所以说一般来说 我们要在组一个爆款标题的时候 一定要遵循下面这三个规则
你只要记得清楚 就是你按照这个规则去选持 然后再根据我们前面所说的那个规则 从左到右搜索指数增长 然后确定持根这样的方式去组
那么你这个标题就是比较完整的 而且是比较符合平台规则 也能够更大的覆盖流量 这样的话 我们在后期无论你沉淀什么样的数据都会得到比较好的一个正向发展
所以一定要记住这几个框架 因为这个对于你一个爆品是否成功 它是有着直接的作用的 一定要重视起来 一个好的标题是爆品成功的一个前提 所以我们记住了这个规则之后 我们就开始去锻炼自己 组多一些标题 看看自己能不能真正的理解
同时也要去推广 可以按照我这种方式去尝试 看看是不是你们的这个行业是非常适合这种方式的 因为绝大部分人的预算是非常有限的 有可能很多人都是50块钱 或者是到200块钱以内 这些有限的预算 我们只能够通过这种方式去带动整个店铺的资源 然后让整个店铺的数据起来 这样是比较好的一种
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里